Rebecca Ford yes I was looking for my 90
pound dumbbells around the office and I
came in here and I saw you so I figured
I'd we'd sit down and have an interview
let's do something fun okay here's what
I'm gonna do I'm going to give you a
list of 23 celebrities you need to do is
if they played warframe what were their
favorite warfare and bjy
okay okay but here's the catch you can
only use one a warframe once it's a
draft out there oh okay Dwayne the rock
Johnson start us off all done
Alice sorry you need to finish the
Johnson part you just needed to save
Dwayne that's good do you need to
explain why for that one or not really I
think it's self-explanatory
I see him as a Greek god or Greek Titan
rather in the collab with Barack Obama
he would be Baruch cuz Baruch and Barack
okay
Fariq is a pacifist group is shows a lot
of restraint when stuff gets thrown at
him Dutch Oh Dame Judi Dench Louise full
name yes Dame Judi Jen denture because
of her legacy in theatre and film we
need a frame with a legacy so I would
make her Meg mag like an OG original uh
yeah yeah she's been around for a while
one of my personal favorites if you know
how to use her we can do exactly people
say that people it's a sweet thought aka
someone quiet shy is watching you're
wrong I don't know okay this is I'm
counting this as one but it's a few
people Oh Charlie Bay oh oh I can guess
who else I'm gonna Oh No well we would
need Equinox cuz you can be Damon and
the Night Man in one I'm gonna do the
whole cast oh yeah you don't you can
take me back that if you want um
would I react it I don't think I would I
would stick with equinox took you night
man okay Equinox
what about Glenn Howerton aka Dennis
[Music]
he's 5-star man's who was a five-star
warframe that's kinda what you have to
ask yourself maybe Nezha
I'm going the cosmetic angle because he
has such a good looking deluxe skin and
he's like a lot of people Caitlin
Olsen's character Deandra sweet Dee
Zephyr it's really good
okay sweet even you brag on teeth okay
Mac Ronald McDonald are we doing fat Mac
or skinny Mac or no we're going to fat
Mackey's grundle okay it's gotta be
that's gonna cost you later oh okay
Grendel and Danny DeVito I guess this
can be either Danny DeVito or Frank I
feel like they're so inseparable hydroid
just cuz I feel like turning into a
puddle or something Frank woods he needs
to be pure hopefully I pronounced this
right gal gadot we will have to put her
with Cora just because like I'm similar
armor and bury the whip and she has her
magical with su I'm really taking these
seriously yeah you are
yeah well okay here's one someone we
both met hey Dave Kojima oh oh oh
limbo cuz limbo is like abstract stops
time freezes time does its own thing
limbo made a super bad game last year
like well actually my words not yours
let's take that people say limbo ruins
their games cuz he stops all the fun I'm
saying okay good answer it can work
someone who I weirdly enough there's a
story this but I won't go into it I met
her at the stats training about Helen
Mirren well Helen Mirren kind of sounds
like mirages I could give her a mirage
maybe just cuz their names because their
name we're doing so well oh no I was
kidding
I think Mirage works because that's good
yeah okay she could flashy flashy
elegant refined I would say her
animations are some of the she vows and
I would see Dame how they're how she
played Queen oh correct I will fact
check this when I'm editing but I
believe Helen Mirren has a butt tattoo
[Music]
David Beckham Vauban explain that with
balls okay good one Victoria Beckham Oh
posh place Octavia of course she's
songsters mixer a song fun quirky okay
those other Spice Girls first of all
don't disrespect the Spice Girls honey
they're gonna go ginger spice Baby Spice
scary spice in sporty spice I can
encapsulate them are we talking like
original spice rolled the motion picture
era Spice Girls I got their peak I can
see I've waded into some dangerous
waters Meatloaf's driving the bus in
that movie I'll leave you to oh you know
what we're gonna go with banshee sound
based I feel like I almost had you okay
Kim Kardashian Oh Kim K so this would be
a fashion frame based decision on my
part cuz like everything she does
someone not necessarily may be used
often but I wisp okay okay this would
have to be Oprah Winfrey
[Music]
I don't want to offend her in case she
watches your blows my stuff yeah Oprah's
gonna be here oh the creepiest warframe
you didn't wanna offend her no I think
like Oprah would be the one to save us
all so look at the same way heritage or
the lore adds up to pocket I'm in New
York right now so I feel like anything I
say will be held against me by the
notorious b.i.g
we have fan clubs right and it's like
nice West Coast viewed and you just
brought up a West Coast rapper mhm in
the East Coast yeah Tupac would be Mesa
um like the Western and he's from the
west coast okay she's like a cowgirl
well this is gonna be difficult than
notorious b.i.g let's see give me the
loot is the best biggie song which means
necrose would be a good fit because his
desecrate gives you the loop you do know
working all right
the protagonists from JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure
oh is it Jojo which part I have no clue
I just I thought it was Jojo so I
thought I'd be if I wrote it like that
it is Jojo but there's five JoJo's cuz
you see when it comes to dessert I mean
I wasn't asking for an anime headache
just pick C pick number between one to
five three okay so that would be Jotaro
Kujo
he's the protagonist of part three
because I already used Atlas this is
just a phone in answer for Jojo
breno right huh right now it's the next
best thing
to what atlas would represent okay
there's one more okay it's Canadian oh
okay just Justin Bieber Oh Justin Bieber
would probably be bolt okay that's good
you got all three legacy yep anyway look
forward thank you so much for stopping
by we're doing another video hopefully
people don't knows we're addressing the
same exact clothes it's switch Clem
still here switch but thanks for
stopping by
it's always nice to sit down and have a
very insightful serious conversation
with you I agree
[Music]